[Music]  ben affleck announces he's completed a  surprise stint in rehab on tuesday the  actor posted this lengthy message to his  fans on facebook it reads in part quote  I want my kids to know there is no shame  in getting help when you need it Wow how  do you make all that work mean you guys  got a lot going on madura bus Ben's  rehab confession comes after  reconciliation rumors surfaced about him  an estranged wife Jennifer Garner Ben  thanks her in his statement I'm lucky to  have the love of my co-parent Jen who  has supported me and cared for our kids  as I've done the work I set out to do a  source close to the oscar-winner tells  ET that Benny's quote feeling good  following treatment adding that he and  jen are still separated our source also  says that Ben was sober at the Oscars in  February he even brought a male sober  coach with him that night  you